telling schools what they should teach
you know i get really tired of everybody
running down teachers i love our
teachers and what they have done through
covid these are real heroes that deserve
our respect
that line from democrat terry mcauliffe
was the defining moment of last night's
virginia gubernatorial debate and
sometimes shocking gaffes or i don't
know freudian slips can define an entire
campaign for better or worse republican
candidate glenn younkin is betting that
it's the latter
we watched parents so upset because
there was such sexually explicit
material in the library i decided to
check the titles at my child's school
both of these books include pedophilia
graphically describes engaging in
fellatio with male minors you vetoed the
bill that would have informed parents
that they were there yeah
stop the bill that i don't think parents
should be telling schools what they
should teach i don't think parents
should teach
glenn young virginia gubernatorial
candidate joins me now glenn thanks so
much for being here your thoughts
uh when you heard mcauliffe say that
when you were on stage with them last
night
i mean what we saw last night on full
display with flashing red lights was
terry mcauliffe's heart
that he believes that that government
and politicians know better for our
children than parents he wants to
exclude parents from being involved in
educating our children you know lor
virginia parents have been standing up
for the rights of their kids for the
last 20 months
fighting against school boards who've
been trying to impose all kinds of
things on them they've been asking for
our schools to be open and what you saw
last night was what they all suspected
that terry mcauliffe does not care what
they believe he wants to dictate what
they learn he wants to teach our
children how to think and he wants to
excuse parents from all of it this is
not just virginia parents lore
every parent in america suspects this is
going on in schools and terry mcauliffe
just told us he's the godfather of the
current progressive democrat party and
here he just showed his heart this is
what they believe
we're having a campaign in virginia
right now we're having a campaign in
virginia right now it's no longer a
campaign it's a movement laura and i
invite everybody to join the movement
join us at younkinforgovernor.com and
watch virginia stand up not just for
virginia parents but for america's
parents all right townhall.com today is
reporting that the mcauliffe send their
kids to a private school um outside of
d.c
and his wife is on the board of trustees
was on the board of trustees for the
school while their kids were students
there now i don't begrudge his wife
wanting to help shape the kids education
at their schools i think that's that's
great
it's a private school i've no problem
with that but
if if his wife can help shape kids
education at school then and she's a
parent of the t like kids why why is
that wrong for anybody else in loudoun
county where they're fighting the
radical transgender stuff happening
there or the critical race theory or any
of these issues
well here's the hypocrisy of terry
mcauliffe and what he wants to be the
ruling class i mean his world view is i
know better than you and yet it doesn't
have to apply to me and we saw it just a
couple weeks ago when he's been calling
for mask mandates and then he boards a
train and violates federal law it won't
even put a mask on i mean what we saw
last night was the full display of his
worldview he wants to force everyone to
join a union and get rid of our right to
work he absolutely wants employers to
fire people who don't get the vaccine
now he wants to shut our parents out of
the education of their children
this is why voters are writing i got to
get into a question really quickly and i
have a quick response northern virginia
is where so many of the voters are in in
this race
very quickly how will you try to appeal
to minority voters in northern virginia
hispanics
indian americans
other americans how would you try to
appeal to them
the broad minority voters in in northern
virginia are just as upset at our school
system as all the parents have been on
display and what we're doing is
listening to them we're sharing with
them a future where we're going to have
charter schools where they can have
choice and guess what they are in fact
part of this movement of parents that
are going to march us to victory this
fall and on behalf of all america
virginians are going to win and make a
statement
rejecting the left liberal progressives
this is going to happen laura is really
really humbling to be part of it glenn a
lot of small businesses in northern
virginia they got just hammered during
this covet thing and uh they want to
just be in business so i'll be
fascinated see what happens hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else